well an olympic medalist is back home in
the silver state
local swimmer erica sullivan took silver
at the tokyo olympics now that she's
back here in the valley
she shared her experience with fans at
the las vegas ballpark tonight
madison kimbrough joins us live from
downtown summerlin with more madison
yes las vegas local erica sullivan is
officially
an olympic silver medalist and we got
the chance to sit down with her here at
the las vegas ballpark
to hear how this win is historical on so
many levels
my dad's rule was just like we have a
pool in our backyard just being you know
vegas kid
he said i want to be able to like turn
away and she can still swim pretty okay
as the daughter of a collegiate swimmer
we'd say she has exceeded
okay as she is now a usa swimming member
olympic silver medalist at just 20 years
old erica sullivan captured the silver
medal in the first ever women's
1500 meter freestyle a feat that has
never been done before
until now this race is considered
historical because
prior to this olympics the 800 was as
high as what they allowed women to do
so this is historically the first 1500
meter freestyle ever in the olympic
games
to be a woman one who was of asian
descent and a part of the lgbtq plus
community
bringing this medal back home to vegas
where her love for swimming began
means everything i'm asian american and
i was able to do it in japan
and i'm also a queer woman so i like and
just me being very you know
a pro woman so to speak getting to do a
historical women's event just really hit
home to me
due to the coronavirus the olympics were
put on hold back in 2020
but sullivan says she is just thankful
she got to be a part of the 2021 tokyo
games
her first time competing in the olympics
honestly there was a point when we
didn't even think the games were going
to happen
and we had this hanging fate over our
heads where
if one of us tested positive we were all
going to go home it was a dream honestly
you know getting to be
with six other girls who are your
closest friends that you've known for a
few years and
work as hard as you can for a common
goal which is bring home some medals for
team usa and
now that sullivan is back home in vegas
what is her next move
college she will start her freshman year
at the university of texas
at austin in the fall reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now